transformers attention is all you need
transformers be it state-of-the-art
transformers are better than anything
else in nlp
hi are you tired hearing about
transformer experiments and you wish
there was higher architectural diversity
when testing on benchmarks in machine
learning but especially in natural
language processing
then congratulations you found the right
video for you
because today we are discussing this
paper
that asks a very natural and interesting
question
are pre-trained convolutional models
better than pre-trained transformers
from this paper we will find out how cnn
based
models whatever that might mean we'll
see in a bit so cnn based models
benefiting from the same amount of
pre-training as
transformers were found to be
competitive or even outperforming
transformers in certain experiments or
at least that's what the abstract of the
paper says miss coffeebean thinks that
in this video you will learn something
about transformers versus cnns but
you will also learn something about the
importance of
framing in papers miss coffeebean what
even makes transformers so successful
what do they
have that other architectures don't well
many things
first they are efficient because things
that
an rnn computed sequentially
transformers compute
in parallel enabling large training
scales and faster computations on larger
data sets than lsdms for example second
and as a consequence the pre-trained and
fine-tuning paradigm
came into fashion in nlp because with
the transformer being more efficient
pre-training became a thing with
language models on larger and larger
amounts of text
you know we're talking about bird
roberta d5 the gpd family
and so on third the transformers enable
contextual representations through
self-attention miss coffee bean i must
stop you there on the contextual bit
contextual representations in
pre-trained language
models were not a first with
transformers
for example elmo and kovi enabled this
already with lstms and also pre-training
and fine-tuning was
not invented with transformers
pre-training was not that big of a thing
in nlp but
certainly in computer vision where
basically every cnn backbone was
pre-trained on imagenet
so this paper now asks what if
convolutional architectures
can actually perform on par with
transformers but
this hypothesis were so far mostly
neglected
and untested since transformers took all
the attention
pun acknowledged but not really intended
what if both the pre-training and the
architectural advances
happened simultaneously with the
transformer but
that this doesn't mean that these two
factors
shouldn't be separated and analyzed
independently
and this what if question this
possibility is what this paper aims to
answer by
just trying it out with cnns or that's
what the paper
says there are recent works showcasing
cnn's on sequence to sequence modeling
too
but this study is the first miss coffee
bean did you check
to be more comprehensively structured on
a range of tasks and
focuses on the pre-trained and
fine-tuned paradigm
or this is what the paper says miss
coffee bean why do you keep
saying this well why the focus on cnns
the paper says it because their window
is smaller than for usual self-attention
you know which was spanning all tokens
therefore they are faster to compute
not suffering from quadratic time and
memory complexity
it's only linear furthermore they
operate locally and do not need this
extra construct of positional encodings
forced into the architecture
but this also means that the global
context cannot be captured by one layer
only
in a convolutional network it is the
succession of layers
that increases the context window or the
field of view to use a computer vision
term
for example for a kernel of the size of
two tokens
if the third token would be radioactive
let's say in yellow
it would mean that after one layer the
first token
doesn't include information from the
third token
but only from itself and the second
token but
after the next layer it also contains
information from the third
token okay this is a very interesting
striding
choice miss coffee bean okay but if
we're going to replace things with
convolutions what about
attention making the transformer so
powerful well does it
really there have been papers recently
showing that replacing learnt attention
matrices with
random matrices does not hurt much and
we do not even want to start about
papers replacing the self-attention
layer with an mlp layer
or even with a fourier transform okay so
to recapitulate the opponents of today's
match
the cnn versus the transformer or this
is what the paper says
let's go in the right ring corner we
have the transformer the well-known
champion the state of the art in nlp
beating t5 well at least a d5 replica
which is
pre-trained on the colossal cleaned
common crawl
corpus with span-based masking
as a pre-training objective which in
english means that
the random spans composed of more words
are masked and the model must fill in
the blanks then
this model is further fine-tuned on
diverse downstream tasks comprising
toxicity detection sentiment or news or
question classification semantic parsing
in the left corner we have the
challenger a sequence to sequence cnn
model which is basically a transformer
architecture but where self-attention is
replaced with convolutional
blocks in other words this paper is
perhaps framed as analyzing
what gains the pre-trained and
fine-tuned paradigm
promises for cnns versus transformers
but it is
actually we replace the self-attention
with
insert here x and this
x happens to be convolutions wow
i i do not know about you but miss
coffee bean thought that this paper was
something different than the mlp
and fnet paper we have seen lately but
in hindsight it is exactly the same
paper pattern replacing the
self-attention layer with something else
this time with convolutions
it's all about the framing therefore
keep in mind that this paper should
not be interpreted as what would have
happened if the transformer did not ever
come
into existence in nlp and a completely
different architecture would have
emerged but
rather as what would happen if one layer
in the transformer would be not
self-attentive but convolutional where
all the rest in the transformer is kept
the same
miss coffee bean really believe that
this paper disentangles the transformer
architecture and the pre-trained and
fine-tuned paradigm
this paper does not really disentangle
much okay rant over
we will discuss this just a little bit
more at the end of the video
so self-attention is replaced with
convolutions in three configurations
lightweight dilated or dynamic
convolutions
in short these words mean the following
a lightweight convolution is when
convolution parameters are shared
every other channel dilated means that
every other
pixel counts when computing the results
of the operation
and the dynamic convolutions are
lightweight convolutions but
with learnable position specific kernels
yay so this cnn in quotes
model is trained and fine-tuned on the
same data
as its opponent with the same masked
span prediction
objective and now we come to the
interesting part
the authors let the two opponents
compete
and well the results on the tasks show
that there
is no clear winner here there are
cases where transformers are better but
also many cases where
convolutional variant is better so this
means that convolutions
also benefit from pre-training that's
acknowledged
that's even expected because even the
convolutional architecture here is
almost a transformer
the authors highlight that convolutions
are not the best
choice in tasks that need
cross-attention between two or more
sequences like in natural language
inference where you must predict the
relation between two sentences
in this case the cross attention
inductive bias is desirable
on the bright side experiments confirm
the theoretical consideration saying
that convolutions are faster the scaling
is linear in sequence length and cnns
are in general more efficient in the
number of floating point operations than
transformers
in conclusion the authors themselves say
that there is no clear winner in this
battle what miss coffee bean likes about
this paper
is that it shows that there is some
architectural tuning that might be
beneficial
on certain tasks the point of discussion
for miss coffee bean is on the last
point made in the paper about
disentangling pre-training and
architectural advances
the authors claim that they showed that
convolutional based
architectures can also benefit from
pre-training
and this is where miss coffee bean
disagrees so here it is she puts her
point up for debate
she might be wrong after all to
understand what cnn based architecture
means here
it also comes down to understanding what
transformer architecture
means in the first place is
self-attention something of
an essence to transformers is a
transformer not a transformer anymore if
one
replaces the self-attention with
something else
be it an it will be a fourier transform
or a convolution
is it still a transformer without its
residual connections or
normalization layers when is a
transformer not a transformer anymore
well this is a hard question to ask for
anything like
when is miss coffee bean not miss coffee
bean anymore if you
remove the arms or the legs or the eyes
this is a hard philosophical question
essentialism
for miss coffee bean self-attention is
not that much of an essence to the
transformer but it is
the exact flow and parallelism of
information where
one starts with a sequence or rather a
set
of tokens then has an aggregating or
mixing layer for all the tokens to
produce
new tokens these newly produced tokens
are then processed individually and not
together and replacing the
self-attention layer with a
convolutional one does not make
the architecture immediately a cnn
it is perhaps a cnn based transformer
but
if we would name it such then a
transformer is an
attention-based transformer what do you
think
what are you allowed to remove from the
transformer to still make it a
transformer
are you happy with the framing of this
paper where they say that
cnns are compared with transformers
or do you think that transformers with
convolutional layers are
still transformers and it's terminology
how
should the naming of these things work
anyway
and with all these questions miss coffee
bean leaves
us okay bye